after days of uncertainty the security
council renewed permission for
humanitarian aid to flow from turkey
into syria but for just six months
it was deeply controversial the uk
france and the us abstained a resolution
with a 12-month timeline which is what
the un and aid agencies requested was
defeated on friday when russia used its
veto the vote we took this morning is
what happens
when one council member takes the entire
security council
hostage
with the lives of syrian men women and
children hanging in the balance
the resolution that was finally passed
was very similar to the one russia had
itself proposed on friday then 13 out of
15 council members had voted against it
norway and ireland introduced the new
version look first of all this was not a
decision taken on the basis of a russian
draft today this was a co-pen holder
russia ireland and norway
draft just a few words different i think
on the face of it you may look at that
and say that james but you know that the
devil is in the detail and i think if
you look at the checks there are
significant differences
what is different is a clause requiring
the un secretary general antonio
guterres to provide a report on the aid
situation by december he gave me his
reaction to the new resolution we have
been asking for the renewal of
that
cross border
point
as it is essential for
the people in italy it's a matter of
life and death for many of them
we have asked for a renewal of
one year
the security council approved six months
but i strongly hope that after this six
months
it will be renewed the head of the human
rights group amnesty international says
the events of recent days show the work
of the security council is now virtually
paralyzed we do need a different system
the security council has run as is
clearly demonstrating that it has run
the end of its path right now something
else need to come up
with just a sixth month extension
members of the security council will
have to renegotiate humanitarian aid in
syria in january that's a time of year
when conditions are particularly tough
for people in northern syria because of
the harsh wintry weather james bay's al
jazeera at the united nations well cena
kosovo has just returned from the turkey
syria border she says ngos working there
believe the veto power of the security
council remains a threat to the delivery
of aid
extending the u.n humanitarian aid
delivery to northern syria for six more
months may ease the tension for now but
it is not seen as a solution
international and local ngos have
already been warning that planning and
implementing such a wide-scale operation
into northwestern syria where 4.5
million civilians reside requires longer
than 6 months time
there are 4.4 million civilians just in
idlib and among all of them 2.4 million
of them depend on international
humanitarian aid that's why they say six
months time will not be a solution to
their problems as the children in idlib
are facing a big risk of hunger and they
are already undernourished and the
majority of the population are children
and women which is seen as the
vulnerable segment of the society some
of the ngos already started showing
their reaction saying that world is just
watching what's going on in idlib and
some of them say that humanitarian
actions should be taken away from u.n
security council as russia's veto is
always a threat for the civilians an
alternative b plan must be established
and local grassroots ngos inside syria
must be empowered
let's speak to matthew bryza who's a
board member of jamestown foundation and
a former american diplomat he's joining
us from cacao welcome to al jazeera once
again so what is your reaction to this
resolution that has now passed that
allows cross-border aid deliveries into
syria and to the rebel-held region for
for six months as opposed to a year
well my first reaction is thank goodness
uh second reaction is yeah russia won
this round of diplomacy um not that it
really matters who won or lost but you
know russia instrumentalizes
uh
the rest of the world's desire to do
humanitarian good uh and in this case it
got a second bite and a third bite at
the apple uh by now only having a
six-month renewal so that six months
from now
russia can try to extract something else
from the international community when
the rest of us are totally desperate in
winter to get that such badly needed
humanitarian aid to those people in
northwest syria but were there any
major differences in the resolution that
russia had put forward just a few days
ago in which
a lot of countries were against and then
there comes this one
um
and it passed i mean we heard from our
reporter james baze at the u.n um
questioning this bill matt saying well
there isn't that much difference in the
resolution so why did it pass now
yeah darren i think james bay's got it
exactly right russia was playing a game
of chicken with the international
community uh it knew that it could force
through its draft uh and the draft that
it wants uh wants basically
to make it more difficult for
humanitarian assistance to get into
northwest syria without the help of the
assad regime uh and so it passed now
because the rest of the world realized
we have to get this aid uh to these the
people who are suffering in northwest
syria so so the rest of the world
blinked and that really meant you know
the united states united kingdom and
friends on the security council uh it's
it's a brutal tactic by russia and i
experienced it when i was still with the
us government uh every year we had to
renew a u.n peacekeeping operation in
georgia
after which or during which russia
invaded and occupied northwest georgia
and russia prevented the provision of
humanitarian assistance to georgians in
the areas that russia had invaded and
occupied uh as a negotiating tool just
like it's doing right now let me just
play devil's advocate for a moment i
mean russia says that it wants to see
the aids come through damascus as you
just said also through the government in
damascus and it insists that you know
this this route violates syrian
sovereignty does russia not have a point
russia definitely has a point there and
the difference is that the rest of us at
least on the security council consider
humanitarian aid uh an end in itself
something that should not be politicized
something that should not be used as a
way to shape the politics on the ground
uh but having said that i mean going
back to the georgia example we much
preferred meaning we being the security
council uh permanent representatives the
united states france and the uk that
that assistance would have come from the
georgian government to the separatist
regions uh rather than from in that case
russia so yeah russia russia has a point
but it also has a different philosophy
it's perfectly willing to
instrumentalize the humanitarian
suffering uh to secure its political
objectives let me just ask you uh just
to give us your thoughts on the
divisions amongst the members of the
security council and particularly uh i
mean there have always been divisions as
we know but particularly these days the
in the wake of of course the the war
taking place in ukraine i mean how would
you describe relations among security
council members right now at present
ah yeah poisonous with regard to russia
versus again the permanent members uh
from the west uk france and united
states uh and it's interesting that by
the way uh china abstained uh on the
resolution a couple of days ago that
that russia vetoed so yeah and china of
course is a member of the p5 uh china
realizes that it's not doing itself any
favors if it too like russia tries to
instrumentalize humanitarian assistance
so relations are really bad in the
security council and you know as as the
french representative was saying in your
package uh the the security council
mechanism really is is broken it doesn't
work now when you've got russia willing
to veto anything that france the uk and
the u.s want and vice versa yeah all
right thank you so much uh matthew prize
ever speaking to us from cacao thank you